hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be breaking down the new ending some
might even say the true ending of the
original seven deadly sins story the new
movie seventh of the sins cursed by
light was finally released on netflix
and it filled in a bunch of the missing
pieces from the original manga and anime
including what happened to the supreme
deity what happened after the main story
of the manga and so on this movie seems
to be completely canon and not only does
it end the original story but it even
sets up the ongoing seven deadly sin
sequel called four nights of the
apocalypse so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the seven deadly sins and four
nights of apocalypse content on this
channel and you want us to keep it going
you know what to do just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps a lot with the youtube
algorithm and if you're new to anime pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror
finally this video will contain spoilers
for the seven deadly sins manga the
seven deadly sins movie cursed by light
and some spoilers for the seven deadly
sin sequel called four nights of
apocalypse so proceed with caution you
have been warned
okay so the plot of the movies takes
place several months after the ending of
the original big manga arcs but before
elizabeth gives birth to tristan diane
and king are about to get married while
meliotis and elizabeth are taking some
time to travel around britannia visiting
the places they had spent time in during
elizabeth's many other lifetimes after
this trip is over meliotis and elizabeth
are planning to get married and assume
the roles of king and queen of leonis
diane and king are initially upset that
meliotis and elizabeth decided to go on
their trip at the same time as their
wedding is taking place but then it
turns out that they just gave the wrong
wedding date to meliotis and elizabeth
which was pretty dumb but whatever
moving on overall this movie definitely
feels like it is canonical to the story
and it feels like it should have been
included as an entire final arc in the
manga itself i really don't know why it
wasn't included to be honest because the
supreme deity was such a massive
unanswered question in the main story
and my best guess is that they just
wanted to make a lot of money from this
movie and they thought that the movie
would do better if it focused on brand
new material as the story unfolds we see
a deadly attack on the demon realm
orchestrated by two individuals one is a
big buff guy with fairy wings who turns
out to be the second fairy king dahlia
and the other is a giant named dubs who
is known as a master craftsman he is the
man who created many important weapons
and artifacts including lost vein and
the coffin of eternal darkness by the
way i'm not sure why dahlia seems to be
just as large as dubs or why he is the
only fairy with a clearly adult-like
appearance maybe he is the child of a
fairy and a giant or something along
those lines but if so this was not made
clear in the movie and then we come to
the one thing that makes this entire
movie worthwhile all on its own gel does
vampire boobs okay i am only half
kidding because her boobs were pretty
great but it turns out that zeldras and
gelda were also taking a romantic trip
of their own and during that trip they
happened to come across meliotis and
elizabeth following some friendly
brotherly rivalry between zeldris and
meliotis including absolutely brutal
battles of rock paper scissors the four
of them make their way to the demon
realm after learning that the realm has
been attacked and as those guys venture
into the demon realm to deal with the
mysterious attackers the anon king's
wedding after party is crashed by a
bunch of giants and fairies who attack
leonis camelot is also attacked at the
same time by angry groups of giants and
fairies who keep screaming about wanting
to make the seven deadly sins and their
allies pay for quote unquote ruining the
holy war but it is clear that all of
these giants and fairies are being
possessed and manipulated by some
outside force but even so they present a
serious threat to the well-being of
leonis and i guess they're also a threat
to camelot but camelot is in ruins
anyway so i don't know what exactly they
can damage there i guess they're just
after arthur and merlin who are shown
briefly in camelot personally i was
surprised to see that so many random
giants are still alive there seemed to
be like hundreds of them who were being
manipulated but i was under the
impression that diane and matrona were
pretty much the last known living giants
in britannia this is probably the
biggest inconsistency in terms of the
story being canon but maybe i'm missing
something so feel free to hit me up down
in the comments where did all these
giants come from and wasn't the giant
clan supposed to be nearly extinct
anyway king the ant bond golther and the
holy knights of leonis get to work on
trying to defeat the invaders and
protect the population of the kingdom
meanwhile in the demon realm meliotis
and zeldras engage in a bitter battle
against dahlia and dubs in this movie we
finally get to see some true brotherly
bonding between meliodas and zeldris
which is something that we were
definitely missing in the original manga
the manga kind of ends just as meliotas
and zeldas make peace with each other
but we don't get to actually see them
being bros and doing brotherly things
this movie finally gives us that and
that is probably my favorite aspect of
the entire movie along with galda's
vampire boobs obviously it turns out
that all of those giants and fairies in
the human realm are being controlled by
dubs who has a magic flute thing which
allows him to control other creatures
he's even able to take control of
meliodas's own lost vein clones and turn
them against him using their cool powers
and abilities dubs and dahlia actually
managed to defeat meliotis and delges at
first and dubs is able to trap meliotis
inside his magical staff at this point
elizabeth remembers that she had known
dahlia back in the time of the first
holy war and back then dalia had no
interest in the war and he refused to
join sigma dubs also didn't seem to
support the war and in fact he created
the coffin of eternal darkness because
he wanted to bring the war to an end so
why are these guys now angry at the
seven deadly sins for ending the second
holy war and on top of that why do they
both seem to be way more powerful now
than they were back when elizabeth knew
them thousands of years ago zeldras
actually manages to free meliotis and
after they realize that weapons made by
dubs are nullified by his magic but
other weapons are still effective
against him meliotas and zeldris are
finally able to defeat dubs and dahlia
about 50 minutes into the movie after
they are knocked unconscious a strange
light leaves dahlia and dubs bodies and
elizabeth realizes that they were both
being controlled by cheat hope the true
mastermind behind these events and the
person who had brainwashed dalia and
dubs was none other than the supreme
deity herself and so
finally the supreme deity makes her way
to center stage an injured mile suddenly
shows up at leonis but he is being
chased and attacked by fellow members of
the goddess clan mile is trying to warn
everyone in lyoness that the supreme
deity has some evil plan cooked up to
finish the holy war once and for all and
that she is the one controlling everyone
including dahlia dubs and those members
of the goddess clan who are currently
attacking him and this little part with
mael really made me think again that
this should have been an entire arc in
the manga not just a short 80-minute
movie as you will recall after being one
of the coolest characters in the entire
story what with the huge esterosa twist
and everything mael lost all our respect
after he refused to fight the demon king
because he was scared that was such an
anti-climactic final chapter for a
character as cool as mael and this
supreme deity arc was the perfect
opportunity for mile to redeem himself
if this part of the story was longer
there could have been an entire mini arc
about mael returning to the celestial
realm realizing that something was wrong
having a crisis of conscience as he
debates whether to go up against the
supreme deity and then finally deciding
to do the right thing and fight against
her thereby making up for his previous
cowardice in the face of the demon king
but in the movie mile gets barely like a
minute of screen time and then at the
56th minute mark the supreme deity
appears and the final battle begins as i
said earlier this is an 80-minute movie
so we're basically two-thirds in by the
time that the main villain even shows up
as you can imagine the final battle
against the supreme deity is indeed epic
but it is also extremely rushed the
supreme deity reveals that she had been
sealed away along with the other
goddesses for over 3000 years but she
had been watching everything that was
happening through the eyes of her
daughter elizabeth the supreme deity did
not want the holy war to end and when
she was finally released from her prison
after the holy war she manipulated
dalian dubs to do her bidding since
meliodas celgius elizabeth and gelda are
still inside the demon realm at this
point the rest of the sins take on the
supreme deity except for merlin of
course who is in camelot and who does
practically nothing in the entire movie
my boy bon definitely shines in this
moment as he attempts to fight the
supreme deity on his own and he proves
once again that he is a true badass
through and through as you guys may know
bond is my favorite character in the
whole story and even though he is
definitely not the main focus of this
movie he does get a few badass moments
to shine so i am happy with that
naturally bonn gother king diane and the
others can't really do much against the
supreme deity and it looks like all of
leonis is about to be destroyed but that
is when meliodas and zeldra's return
along with elizabeth and gelda meliotis
uses full counter to save leonis and all
of his friends in the nick of time and
meliodas then reveals that back when he
was possessed by his father the demon
king he understood the true nature of
the holy war the supreme deity and the
demon king were locked in an eternal
conflict ever since they first came into
existence and so the holy war for them
was just an endless game they believed
that constant conflict between the
demons and goddesses was the natural way
of the world and they also believed that
this was the only way to maintain
balance and order if this balance was
ever to be disturbed an age of chaos
would take its place in the climax of
the film meliotis and teldrass worked
together to take down the supreme deity
there are some great moments in this
fight as i said it is awesome to see
melios and zelda working together as
brothers and also the final attack that
takes the supreme deity down is an epic
combo move called tyrant killing this
move was definitely incredible i don't
want to take anything away from it but
overall the fight against the supreme
deity was just too rushed and it made it
seem like defeating a literal god like
the supreme deity was just way too easy
now of course i know that the battle had
to be rushed because this was only an 80
minute movie but after the demon king
got multiple arcs in the manga the
supreme deity deserved the same
treatment this entire story that the
movie covers is perfectly fine as the
final arc in the story but it should
have been an entire extended arc in the
manga or an entire season or at least
half season of the anime trying to cover
everything in just one movie just seemed
way too rushed and it made the supreme
deity seem underwhelming as a villain
after the high expectations that we had
built up for her after all of these
years and i mean come on elizabeth
should have played a bigger role in this
battle she is the supreme deity's
daughter and it would have been so much
better if she also played a pivotal part
in actually taking the supreme deity
down finally i was not a fan of the
supreme deity cgi but that's not a big
deal at the end of the day as the battle
comes to an end we see merlin looking
down upon everyone from the clouds with
her morning star while then and yet
doing nothing merlin then declares that
the age of gods is over meaning that the
age of chaos is about to begin and this
sets up the currently ongoing seven
deadly sin sequel called four knights of
the apocalypse
at this early stage in the sequel story
merlin and arthur appear to be the main
villains which is really interesting if
you are a seven deadly sins fan and you
haven't checked out the sequel yet i
definitely recommend that you do if you
have a crunchyroll membership already
the sequel manga four knights of the
apocalypse is available for free in
their manga section and if you want to
see more videos about the sequel here on
the channel definitely like this video
and subscribe for more the movie ends
with the wedding of elizabeth and
meliotis and with their crowning as the
queen and king of leonis hawk and wild
arrived just in time for the banquet
otherwise they played pretty much no
role in the whole story and as meliotis
and zeldris continue to bond as brothers
the final credits roll overall as i said
multiple times i consider this movie to
be canon and the story it covers would
have been a great final arc if it had
been expanded into a real manga arc in
terms of this short 80 minute movie i
would give it like a seven out of ten
there are some great elements here like
meliotis and zelda's bonding and vampire
boobs but the story could have been done
so much better if it wasn't rushed
frankly i think they should adapt this
movie into an extended manga arc that
would serve as an addendum to the
original manga because this really did
answer a lot of our unanswered questions
and i liked it overall but it just needs
to have more meat on the bones let me
know what you guys think did you like
the movie and do you feel that it was a
fitting final arc for the story do you
agree with me that it was good but
rushed and would you like to see the
story from the movie adapted into an
extended manga arc that does all of
these plot points more justice finally
how do you think that the events of the
movie fit into the seven deadly sins
sequel manga and do you think that this
movie gives us any clues for why arthur
and merlin turned into villains don't
forget to share your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
seven deadly sins video and you want to
see more seven deadly sins and four
nights of the apocalypse videos here on
the channel don't forget to leave that
like it only takes a second but it helps
a lot and if you're new to animal pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a quick
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma this man is an absolute mad lad
and a disciple of lord twigo himself and
i can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algital hinokamian water the toasted chi
the spike corey mcgowan kaido might be a
gyarados dylan isidor spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody hebert
monkey d quilly and jeremy cummings
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red-haired raven angel
cruz rathundara very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joy and garcia ted no ted
and fat boy games if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you